Remember that Ethan was already going
after all these people. The CPS and
Skulls incidents just gave him the
justification he needed to escalate.
On June 19th, Ethan announced in a video
>> Wow, who who would who would think
something so stupid? Who would ever
think something so [__] stupid? The
CPS is a is an explicit uh justification
to to escalate. Who would ever think
something so stupid? Who would ever say
something so [__] stupid?
It's the time to escalate. No, I'm
sorry. You you only get to do this for
so long. No, it's the time for lawsuits.
It's the time to escalate. It's the time
to go for blood. No, it absolutely is.
I'm sorry.
>> sharing information instead of video
titled I'm suing these three creators
that he had registered his content nuke
video on Hasan with the US Copyright
Office, a move that federally protects
the work from infringers. He went on to
name Denims, Frogan, and Casey Tron as
the three targets for newly filed
copyright infringement lawsuits. To me,
this is sort of the culmination of
Ethan's feud with the Hasan sphere. He
says he was laying a trap for certain
creators and claims he knew they'd react
to his video with minimal commentary and
essentially steal his content.
>> that I wanted these people to steal my
video, it's that I knew they would.
>> [music]
>> I knew they would watch the entire
video, add little to no commentary,
>> [music]
>> react to it instantly, giving them no
time to form an opinion. I don't even
know what that last part means, by the
way. Like, what they should have waited
a few days to watch your video? Like,
what was he even trying to say there?
Regardless, his cases do seem pretty
strong. Specifically, Casey Tron and
Frogans reactions to the content nuke
appear pretty short and lacking in
meaningful commentary, and the primary
defense against copyright infringement,
which is fair use, likely wouldn't work
for them. But, in classic Ethan Klein
fashion, he's been extremely dishonest
about his intentions and what these
lawsuits are actually about.
>> Interesting. For starters, Ethan claims
in his video
>> the point that his entire mission is to
fight against content theft and stand up
to lazy react streamers.
>> Why should these content thieves,
essentially, get more views than the
author of the video, which in a lot of
cases was happening. I mean, people
don't like injustice, and this just we
all see this and know it's not right.
>> But his criteria for who he decided to
sue was a little more specific than just
those who watched the content Nuk can
fall.
>> There were a few people that went above
and beyond to commit copyright
infringement. These people not only
violated all of the principles of fair
use, they also did it maliciously, and
that's the part that really got me. It's
the stated malicious intent to steal.
>> And I suggest you all watch it through
other people as well. If you enjoyed um
not giving any views to that terrible
video, follow, [music] subscribe.
>> of people have been wanting to watch
this without necessarily supporting
Ethan Klein. So, Ethan is targeting
people who maliciously reacted by openly
stating that they wanted to avoid
supporting his channel, and to a lot of
people, that makes sense. Go after the
people who were trying to harm your
channel. But the problem is that both
legally and logically, the concept of a
quote malicious reaction is kind of
[__] incoherent. [music] So, legally,
any focus on malice in a copyright
lawsuit would be a misapplication of
copyright law. In US copyright law,
especially when arguing for fair use,
intent or malice
>> Yeah, so it it's a you know, it's
statutory, right? It's just about the
offense, it's not about the intent. It's
not actually, you know, it doesn't
matter whether you intended to be nice
when you're reacting, it's still
copyright infringement. has pretty much
nothing to do with whether infringement
has actually occurred. The primary test
for fair use focuses on four factors,
mainly whether the work has been
sufficiently transformed by adding new
meaning or commentary. But intent or
malice is not one of those four factors.
Someone could be completely unaware that
material they're using is even
copyrighted, and they can still be found
guilty of infringement. Malice might
come into play later when determining
damages, but legally, it's completely
irrelevant to whether anyone's guilty of
copyright infringement. And logically,
Ethan's focus on malice doesn't really
make sense, either. Look at it this way.
If somebody steals your property,
whatever they say they're doing isn't
really relevant. If someone steals a
bike from your front yard and rides away
saying it's okay, I'm not stealing it,
I'm just riding it, they're still
stealing your bike. They're receiving
all the benefits of theft and you're
experiencing all the harm of it,
regardless of what they said they were
doing.
>> now pasta with the lemon and lime
character relaxing on a beach. Thank
you. That's content, it's the same
thing. If you watch someone's entire
video on stream, you've taken their
content and given your audience a
version they can watch instead of you
watching it.
Whether you say I'm stealing your
viewers or you say I love this creator,
it doesn't change what you're doing. The
only thing that matters here is whether
or not your coverage adds enough to the
original video to make it a
fundamentally different product, which
would mean you're no longer stealing.
And furthermore, everyone who reacts to
an entire video on stream with minimal
commentary knows that that's what's
happening. They know their audience is
watching through them instead of going
to the original. That's not a secret,
that's how the genre works.
>> We all watch both, don't we guys? We all
watch both. So if somebody knows they're
stealing viewers and they choose to do
it anyway, isn't that literally
>> with the eye. literally the definition
of malice? So then what's the difference
between what these three women did and
anyone else who gave a low effort
reaction to the content [music] nuke?
Well, materially there isn't one. All of
them willfully chose to steal Ethan's
channel of potential viewers. The only
difference is Denims, Frogan, and
Keemstar said those words out loud. I do
want to briefly point out that I'm not
even really sure that Denims or Keemstar
did in fact openly state an intent to
steal views. I know Ethan's convinced
everyone that that's what happened, but
look at what they actually said. Denims
responded to a chatter saying they
wanted to watch the content nuke through
someone else and simply confirms that
she is in fact going to react to it,
which isn't really malicious. At the end
of the video she makes the comment from
earlier. If you enjoy not giving any
views to that terrible video, follow,
subscribe, etc. That's not really
malicious intent either. The video's
already over and it's simply an
acknowledgement that some people were
there for that reason. Same thing with
Keemstar. A lot of people have been
wanting to watch this without
necessarily supporting Ethan Klein.
That's not really a statement of intent.
It's just kind of a fact. And that's all
she said. So, is this really them saying
they're trying to steal Ethan's views?
I'm not really convinced of that. They
seem more like statements of awareness
about the market for boycotting Ethan
Klein's channel. But, let's leave that
aside. Let's say these were explicit
statements of malicious intent. There's
another creator who Ethan is not suing
who did the exact same thing. xQc
proudly admitted that he is stealing
Ethan's content during his reaction.
>> Yeah. So, he literally says, "We're
watching. We're watching. We're
watching." Thank you for the five
Canadian Alpus. Huge appreciate. Thank
you so much. Thank you. I I actually
admitted watching it. I admitted
watching it. People think it's reacting
on stream? No. Watching it. I'm not
reacting to this. I'm watching this.
What about it? If Ethan actually cared
about his property
>> Yeah. What about it? xQc is a prime
example of somebody he should be going
after. He reacted to the content nuke in
full with minimal commentary. He's got a
massive audience and he's openly
admitted he doesn't care about
intellectual property. To Ethan.
>> So, in that regard, do you care at all
about like IP or copyright? Does that
matter to you?
Uh, no. It doesn't matter.
Well, if if flat-out doesn't. During
that same debate, Ethan specifically
called out xQc for using deceptive
thumbnails, taking the original
creator's thumbnail and slapping his
face on it to confuse audiences and
siphon views.
>> The fact that you're using the same
title and the same thumbnail is so
parasitic. It's so shady. You You are
only doing that to siphon off views and
confuse people. There's no other reason
for that. But, that's exactly what xQc
did with the content nuke. By Ethan's
own standards, xQc should be
>> write that, dude. That's exactly what
xQc did with the content nuke. By
Ethan's own standards, xQc should be the
first person he would go after. But,
when he watches him proudly admitting to
stealing his property, he has only nice
things to say.
>> I'm not reacting to this. I'm watching
this. What about it? And I And listen, I
respect you, man. I acknowledge you. We
hear you. I acknowledge you.
>> a [__] line. Totally [__] cocked.
Right by the worm. Right by the watch.
So, I literally started getting into
watches cuz XQC mocked them and was
like, "I got I got your house on my
wrist. I got your house on my wrist."
And then Diorio gets into it, too, man.
That's the saddest part. That's the
saddest part. Look at this [__] So, is
Ethan just a [__] who won't go after
someone that has the money to fight
back?
Yes.
But more importantly, this shows that
the lawsuits have nothing to do with
malice or lazy react content or
protecting intellectual property. This
is just a targeted attack on specific
people that Ethan doesn't like, which is
not really what the court system is
meant for. And of the people Ethan is
suing, Dennis's the clearest example of
just how bad faith he's being here. I
mean, Ethan spends his entire
announcement video talking about the
harm of lazy react streamers, like
people who walk away from the video and
leave it playing.
>> The problem seems to have only gotten
worse. [music] You have people like
Hasan [__] paving the way of fair use
with what's known as chair reacts. When
Hasan gets up, disappears for extended
period of time, and leaves the video
playing for his chair. Mr. Chair, they
call it. But Dennis's video was nothing
like that. The content nuke itself is
less than 2 hours long, and Dennis's
reaction to it is almost 4 hours long.
And according to Ethan's own standard,
that should qualify as being
transformative.
>> My reacting to Ian's content cop, which
I finished in my my total reaction was
probably what, like 5 hours or something
in total? Maybe less, four. And his was
an hour and a half. I think that sounds
pretty reasonable. That's like taking
two times more than the original
>> does he want Hasan to do? Starve? You
want him to starve? You want him to just
sit there in his chair and not eat all
day? Oh, okay, fine. I guess I guess
Hasan has to starve then. I guess time,
which seems like a good amount to
contribute to have proper commentary,
right? So, again, by his own measure of
what fair use is, Dennis sufficiently
transformed his video, which should mean
she didn't really steal anything. So,
why then is Ethan still suing her?
Curious.
Ethan Wait, could he be suing him for
something else as well? had a problem.
He wanted to sue Denims, but as of right
now, there really isn't that much legal
precedent for full-length live react
content like this. So, it's pretty
unclear whether Denims' reaction to the
Content Nuke would legally be found to
be an infringement on copyright,
especially given the length and added
commentary. And because Ethan couldn't
know for sure, he decided to hedge. Some
of you guys out there [music] sweating?
He didn't just register the Content Nuke
with the US Copyright Office. He also
registered the countdown stream that led
up to it on the H3 Podcast, which Denims
did watch live. And her reaction to this
countdown stream is far less likely to
fall under fair use.
>> This is so crazy. Obviously, I've spoken
about this a lot, but yeah, he registers
this later on.
>> given the length and added commentary.
And because Ethan couldn't know for
sure, he decided to hedge. Some of you
guys out there sweating? He didn't just
register the Content Nuke with the US
Copyright Office. He also registered the
countdown stream that led up to it on
the
which Denims did watch live. And her
reaction to this countdown stream is far
less likely to fall under fair use. But
the problem is this countdown stream
doesn't seem like it's what Ethan was
talking about when he expressed wanting
to protect people's content. In his
announcement video, he repeatedly
mentions long-form content and uses
Leminno, whose videos likely take weeks
or months to make, as an example of
unfairness.
>> What if I could make a long-form
Obviously, the point that's being made
in this video is about prepared
long-form content. It's about edited
stuff. It's not about your [__] live
streams. It's not about some stupid
countdown where you've just got a ticker
on the screen. It's obviously about
long-form, prepared, edited content. Cuz
that's what he knew was a winning topic.
So, he just hides the fact that they're
suing over the the the countdown episode
as well. resistible piece of content
that I knew that these streamers
couldn't resist. They couldn't avoid the
temptation of watching it the second it
was published.
>> So, he's clearly making it sound like
he's talking about video essays and
things with high production quality, not
some countdown stream. He specifically
talks about Denims here as those she
reacted to the content nuke itself with
no commentary.
>> I knew they would watch the entire
video, add little to no commentary.
[music]
After being gone for a few minutes, she
returns and then sits silently for
another couple of minutes eating. But,
he doesn't mention the countdown stream
a single time. It's almost like he
doesn't want you to realize that he's
completely spite-driven and full of
[__] lying. Maybe I am. So, what? And
here's what makes that super obvious.
Ethan didn't even register the countdown
stream with the content [music] nuke
back in January. He did it in March, 2
months later. What happened It's so
transparent. that would make Ethan want
to be sure he could go after Denims?
That it seems like she's directly
responsible for CPS coming to my [music]
house in the morning and interviewing my
children.
These basically are not even really
copyright lawsuits. It's quite obvious
that Ethan just came up with a way to
use the legal system against his
personal enemies. And the ultimate goal
of his plan was to threaten them with
something that they couldn't fight back
against. Take Casey Choun and Frogan for
instance. These two have pretty small
audiences. They could not have
meaningfully impacted Ethan's income at
all. But, Ethan is pursuing statutory
damages, meaning his payout wouldn't be
based on any actual lost revenue, but a
fixed amount that the court decides upon
[music] and could be up to $150,000.
He's also asking for attorney's fees and
pre-judgment interest just for good
measure. This is Ethan applying the
absolute maximum amount of financial
pressure possible. He's not really
trying to right a wrong. He's trying to
make the cost of defense so high that
they don't actually have a choice. Casey
Choun for instance expressed concern
about losing her home as a result of the
lawsuit. And when she's facing that
level of People want to act like, "Oh,
what what do you want? You want people
with money just never be able to sue
anyone ever? You trying to take people
with money's rights away? You trying to
take rich people's rights away and stop
them from ever suing anyone ever?" As if
like you have to go out and file
malicious lawsuits. That's like a a need
of yours. That's a that's a
something that Ethan absolutely has to
do is go and file malicious harassing
and vindictive lawsuits. and mental
threat. She doesn't realistically have
the option of trying to prove whether
she's right or wrong. She's probably
going to just decide to not risk losing
her house, which is likely why Casey
Chae was the first of the three
defendants to resolve her case. The two
parties settled in December, and as part
[music] of that settlement, she was
required to deliver an on-stream
apology, a statement which consisted of
roughly 26 seconds discussing the
importance of copyright followed by
almost 3 minutes of things like this. I
also want to make clear that I did not
receive any support, financial or
otherwise, from Hasan [__] Hasan never
even reached out to me privately to Oh,
Hasan Hasan Jesus Christ. Hasan is
currently shilling the video live. He's
currently shilling the video live. offer
words of support. I also want to take
the opportunity to acknowledge other
misconduct and bad behavior I have
exhibited online. For example,
weaponizing the death of Asmongold's
mother was inexcusable. AB, along with
his wife Lena, have done more than I
have ever done for the Palestinian
people. I apologize to Ethan and Hila
personally. I have said extremely mean
and cruel things about both of them. I
also want to acknowledge the pervasive
problem of anti-Semitism in leftist
spaces. It should concern all of us.
>> I do. I condemn it and will not
participate in it. To that end, I wish
the clients success in enforcing 100
Entertainment's copyright and protecting
the legal rights of online content
creators. Ethan claims that these
lawsuits weren't about the money, and he
did this to protect the wider commentary
community.
>> Even though theoretically I could sue a
lot more creators and rake in millions
of dollars, the purpose of this is not
financial gain. I don't want to chill
the reaction community into How are
people on Ethan's side after this
hostage video? Well, because they have
like the mindset of like rapists and
child molesters, and they like seeing
people weak and them in uncomfortable
positions where they can't fight back,
um, basically. Fear. Actually the
opposite. I hope that we can all unite
against this type of egregious behavior
that not only makes us all look bad, but
could destroy the commentary community
as we know it. But when he was able to
point a dollar bill shaped gun at
Keemstar's head and force her to say
whatever he wanted, even his
intellectual property became an
afterthought. He was almost exclusively
interested in humiliating her, sucking
up to Asmongold, dunking on his son,
[music] and otherwise just trying to win
his little interpersonal online battles.
Oh, and then boldly [__] lying
afterwards that he had sympathy for
Keemstar and that the apology was
genuine.
>> I think ultimately her her apology was
heartfelt and sincere. You would have to
be a total idiot to actually believe
that. It's incredibly stressful both
emotionally and financially to go
through a lawsuit.
>> It is. And I appreciate the the the
situation she's been in.
>> [clears throat]
>> You're the one putting strain on her
situation. Ethan even made Keemstar
declare her willingness to help him
pursue snark moderators who he claims
colluded with the defendants to promote
their streams.
>> For the record, I have agreed to
cooperate with the clients in their
litigation against the H3 snark mods for
promoting my live stream to the extent
[music] that I am able. But his evidence
for this is just this Reddit post
listing publicly announced streams that
were going to be reacting to the content
news.
>> She's working directly with the snark
subreddit moderators to siphon [music]
views and their intentions couldn't be
clearer.
>> But there's been no evidence presented
of any two-way communication between the
defendants and H3 snark. So Ethan's even
using these coercive statements to
promote narratives about his enemies
that he likely doesn't even have
evidence for, which means that these
totally spite driven copyright lawsuits
are being weaponized to compel the
speech of the people that Ethan is
feuding with and all of it is in service
of simply managing his online
reputation. He and she is just trying
astroturf like a win in drama,
basically. And like I keep saying, rats
like the Oreo going along with it for
the whole last year. Seriously, I like
see anyone actually contest the
arguments in this video. The Oreo would
be a total [__] mess trying to do it.
Imagine him try to figure his way out
figure his way through this. Trying to
explain, "Dude, you saw him try and
figure out how long Denim's reaction was
compared to his." Where he was trying to
figure out whether whether what was it?
Whether two 230 minutes was longer than
3 hours or not. Uh he couldn't figure it
He's like, "Dude, yeah. Dude, I owned
her. My reaction's way longer. My
reaction's like 3 hours. That's way
longer than 230 minutes." Imagine him
trying trying to argue with this video.
There's a reason he won't watch it. And
even if you hate Hasan and [music]
Denims and all these people, what Ethan
is doing here should repulse you because
it's extremely clear that his
announcement video, the forced apology,
his acceptance of the apology, this
entire situation was a lie and he lied
because Ethan knows what he's doing is
[__] up. He knows it's wrong to abuse
the court to litigate personal
grievances. So, he has to pretend to be
doing it for some greater purpose. I
mean, people don't like injustice and
this just [music] we all see this and
know it's not right. I hope that we can
all unite against this type of egregious
behavior that could destroy the
commentary community as we know it.
Ethan, [music] don't settle. Bleed her
bank account bone dry. That's not my
intention. My intention is just to
obviously stand up for what's right. But
that's obviously not what's happening.
None of what Ethan is doing will help
the react community. These cases won't
establish any helpful legal precedent
and he's not even setting a social
precedent against blatantly stealing
content because he's letting the most
long-time egregious offenders off the
hook. The precedent that Ethan is
setting is that wealthy creators can use
the threat of litigation to suppress the
speech of people they dislike and
despite Ethan claiming he wants to avoid
a chilling effect
>> want to chill the reaction community
[music] into fear. This will establish a
totally different kind of one.
Spy-driven lawsuits like this threaten
the entire foundation of online
commentary. Healthy internet ecosystems
thrive on creators engaging with each
other's work. Commentary, criticism,
live reactions, whether positive or
negative, these things expose audiences
to new creators, generate more content,
and keep the space dynamic and
interesting. Creators respond to each
other, build it off each other's ideas,
and issue criticisms. But weaponizing
the legal system over personal beef
undermines all of that, and Ethan knows
it. That's the reason he's doing it.
Maybe if there were a legitimate
standard that they could use, then they
could get behind him. Totally undeniable
what's happening. He didn't go after
everyone who actually stole his
property. He didn't go after people who
meaningfully affected his income. He
didn't even go after the people who
actually set the current standards for
the thing he claims to be concerned
about. He went after three small-scale
creators
that he hates, and he's using his vastly
superior wealth to force them to say
whatever he wants, attacking his
enemies, making political statements
they likely don't believe, and
humiliating themselves publicly.
>> [laughter]
>> to your face about what he's actually
doing. And the thing is, it doesn't
matter whether Keemstar is a good person
or whether she said shitty things about
people. It doesn't matter what Denims or
Frogan have done in the past. What
matters is whether you think someone
with money should be able to abuse the
court to silence their enemies speech
and expression because that is the
standard Ethan is setting. Not a
standard about transformation, not one
about protecting intellectual property.
It's just the standard of don't piss off
Ethan Klein. And if you're not disgusted
by that notion, you should be.
Ethan would be.
In this country, we value free [music]
speech. And what a reaction video
ultimately is is free speech.
>> I think if you're a reactor on Twitch,
if you make a good faith effort [music]
to comment, and if you make a good faith
effort to promote the author, to link to
them,
>> [music]
>> to try to drive traffic to the original
video, I think you're probably pretty
much doing the right thing, and that's
fine.
>> Fair use doesn't give a [__] if you
watch the video first or not. I didn't
watch this video first. I knew they
would watch the entire react [music] to
it instantly, giving them no time to
form an opinion.
>> I have to show that I watched it. It's
literally it's crazy. It's a one-to-one
contradiction.
>> Try to drive traffic to the original
video. I think you're probably pretty
much doing the right thing, and that's
fine. Fair use doesn't give a [__] if
you watch the video first or not. I
didn't watch this video first. I knew
they would watch the entire video, react
to it instantly, giving them no time to
form an opinion.
>> I have to show that I've watched it
before and thought, "I have something
good to add." I didn't watch your video
beforehand, bro.
>> a long-form [music] irresistible piece
of content that I knew that these
streamers couldn't resist. They couldn't
avoid the temptation of watching it the
second it was published. [music]
>> It's speech, bro. I don't need anyone's
permission to say anything.
>> You can't just say whatever you want.
You can't just say, "I'm in favor of
genocide." You got to watch what you
say.
>> I'm not standing by this [__] anymore,
and I'm going to call out people like
Brendan, too, because this is just bad
for everyone. And it's especially
egregious considering [music] the
hypocrisy of the whole free speech thing
that these guys apparently love so well.
>> Free speech. You got to free speech.
>> Shut up, dumbass. [music] You're
shutting down criticism, and you're
pretending like it's a copyright issue.
It's not. It's fair use. It's protected
speech.
>> This isn't a free speech issue. This is
people are [__] getting way too
comfortable slandering and saying
whatever they want about people online
under the guise of free speech.
>> There's lots of videos [__] on me on
the internet. You know, I wish I could
just delete them off the internet, you
know, wouldn't that be nice? Wouldn't
that be just convenient just to But But,
you know what? You can't do it.
That's free speech. Right.
>> and free speech is tested when it's
targeted at you. You can't just say
whatever the [__] you want. It's time to
start holding people accountable for the
[__] they're saying.
>> I what what do you even say? This is
just so [__] like and it should be
obvious as well. Everyone's hard even
saying this [__] The idea that people
can't put [__] two and two together
and just recognize where the obvious
contradictions are on their own is so
[__] damning. It's crazy. The fact
the Oreo has gotten away for so long
with sweep of this [__] is crazy. When
he's got all these same quotes, too.
He's got all these same quotes, too.
Trust me, he's got all these probably
pretty much doing the right thing, and
that's fine. Fair use doesn't give a
[__] if you watched the video first or
not. I didn't watch this video first. I
knew they would watch the entire video,
react to it instantly, giving them no
time [music] to form an opinion. I have
to show that I've watched it before and
thought I have something good to add. I
didn't watch your video beforehand, bro.
>> a long-form irresistible piece of
content that I knew that these streamers
couldn't resist. They couldn't avoid the
temptation of watching it the second it
was published.
>> It's speech, bro. I don't need anyone's
permission to say anything.
>> You can't just say whatever you want.
You can't just say I'm in favor of
genocide. You got to watch what you say.
I'm not standing by this [__] anymore.
And I'm going to call out people like
Brendan, too, because this is just bad
for everyone. And it's especially
egregious considering [music] the
hypocrisy of the whole free speech thing
that these guys apparently love so well.
>> Free speech. You go to free speech. Shut
up, dumbass. You're shutting down
criticism and you're pretending like
it's a copyright issue. It's not. It's
fair use. It's protected speech.
>> This isn't a free speech issue. This is
people are [__] getting way too
comfortable slandering and saying
whatever they want about people online
under the guise of free speech.
>> There's lots of videos [__] on me on
the internet. You know, I wish I could
just delete them off the internet, you
know, wouldn't that be nice? Wouldn't
that be just convenient? Just to But you
know what? You can't do it.
That's free speech.
You know, and free speech is tested when
it's targeted at you. You can't just say
whatever the [__] you want. It's [music]
time to start holding people accountable
for the [__] they're saying.
>> I fight every day to protect free
speech. I put my money on the line. I go
to court. And I'll do it as many times
as I need to.
>> You guys have been doing this for years.
[music] It's the the jig is up. You're
going to have to tell it to a judge,
literally. By the way, this guy likes
threatening to sue people all over fair
use and my right to free speech.
>> I wanted to sue you, I probably could
[__] ruin your whole life.
>> It'll be great to sue them.
>> I'd love to sue her.
>> I'd love to sue him.
>> I'm going to sue you. It's not a threat.
I'm going to sue you. We get to pursue
legal fees for this garbage anti-free
speech lawsuit.
>> And to all the detractors who are saying
that I'm a hypocrite for suing for
copyright infringement, I just have this
[music] to say.
I don't care. It's easy to defend free
speech when it's got nothing to do with
you, right? When it makes you look good.
But when free speech makes you look bad,
[music] then let's see how much you
defend it.
But the moment online criticism became
too difficult for him to handle, all of
those principles went out the window.
And not only has he completely abandoned
those principles, he's become the thing
that he spent so much of his career
complaining about. As an example, look
at the initial complaints for the
lawsuits. These were over 80 pages long
and contain things like a comparison
between Hassan and Haj Amin al-Husseini,
a notable Nazi collaborator during World
War
II. And this was clearly partially
intended to waste opposing counsel's
time and rack up the defendant's legal
fees. But Ethan's been on the receiving
end of litigation like this before.
>> He's doing a spite lawsuit trying to
ruin our lives. And God forbid I
actually fight back against a [__]
total fraudulent copyright lawsuit.
Well, [__] you, bro. Or how he spent the
last 2 years complaining about online
harassment, but in the versions of these
complaints that Ethan linked under his
announcement video, he censored his
lawyer's contact information, obviously
to try to prevent harassment, but he did
nothing to protect the identities of the
three defendants, which were previously
not widely known. Bro,
what would you call this, guys, when you
intentionally publish information,
knowing, likely intending for that
information to be more widely available
to those who might want to do that
person harm? What would you call that?
What would you call it? Yeah, yeah,
unmasking, phone booking, journalism.
There's a few names I can think of for
it. There's a few names I can think of
for it. That's I mean, sure, court
filings are public, but then why censor
anything at all? Ethan knew what he was
trying to protect his lawyer from, but
he declined to try to offer that same
protection to the defendants and
published it to millions of people. I
don't know if most people would think of
this as doxing, but I don't know what
else to call it. And if that is what
this was, we shouldn't be surprised. It
did I mean, it just is. It just is
doxing. They took the legal document.
They censored his lawyer's information,
and then they published it, not
censoring the opponent opposing
counsel's information. That shows a
clear intent. I'm sorry, that does. You
are showing you know that could be harm
done to people whose information is
shared in these documents. You've chosen
to create a copy, a new version. It's
not the version publicly available on
CourtListener, it's a new version for
Internet Archive as a download. They
have the copy, censor lawyers'
information, choose not to censor the
very nearby opposing counsel
information, post it. That's doxxing.
That's doxxing. Ethan has clearly shown,
time and time again, that he has no
standards of any kind. I mean, like back
during the Matt Hoss lawsuit, I can't
speak for everybody, but I supported
Ethan. Yes, partially because of fair
use, but also because it was obvious
that Matt Hoss simply didn't like that
someone was making fun of him. It was
clearly a case of someone that was using
copyright law to go after their enemies.
But now that's Ethan. Sorry, my I my
digital redaction pen just just ran out.
Just ran out. That's why I'm shaking my
digital reaction pen or redaction pen
right right now. You hear that? There's
no ink left. And he's like this with
everything. He condemns things when they
work against him, but he's perfectly
fine with them when they work for him.
Like he considers it harassment when
people contact his sponsors over his own
controversial statements, but it's
totally fine to contact sponsors when he
decides it's okay. It must be nice to be
racist, openly racist, bigoted, and
Twitch does nothing. Capcom, Samsung,
and Chevron should absolutely know about
what kind of content Twitch is putting
in front of their logo. Or how he thinks
snark is the worst possible thing on the
internet, but he didn't have a problem
with it when it was someone else. His
own community is basically Hasan's snark
at this point, and they're just
mimicking his own behavior. And he's the
type of guy that keeps his girlfriend a
secret. I'll just spill the beans. I
don't care at all about him. I asked, I
said, "Why do you keep your relationship
with Valkyrae a secret?"
>> And it was his decision. He likes
everybody W song. W song. That's
obviously why not
>> He hates people bringing up personal
sensitive stuff, like talking about his
dead dog, but he'll readily reveal
intimate private details about people
whenever he wants. Seriously, how do you
think Ethan would react
>> this
>> is how guys like totally [__] awesome
and make his makes his girlfriend like
not say they're together in public so
that he can appear single. Okay okay
Ethan. All right. Yeah, I'd much rather
have an ugly Israeli wife. You're right.
No, you're right. 2026, if someone made
an entire website dedicated to comparing
him to I don't know. How about convicted
stuff. Like talking about his dead dog,
but he'll readily reveal intimate
private details about people whenever he
wants. Seriously, how do you think Ethan
would react in 2026 if someone made an
entire website Dude, so this is this is
it. This is a huge moment for the video
here guys. wants. Seriously, how do you
think Ethan would react in 2026 if
someone made an entire website dedicated
to comparing him to I don't know. How
about convicted mass murderer and child
rapist John Wayne Gacy, which I did do
by the way. So, I guess we'll see.
Anyway, the point So guys, you can now
go to Is Is the link in the description?
The link's not in the description. What
Where's the Where's the [__] website?
Here it is. Guys, you can now go to does
Ethan Klein look like johnwaynegacy.com.
Interesting proposition here. Just
floating that one. I'm a long time
viewer of H3.
I even own a Teddy Fresh hoodie.
Although I've only been wearing it at
home after my friends made fun of me for
it. But recently something happened that
entirely changed my perspective on the
H3 H3 show. When I was watching the
podcast on living room TV, my roommate I
was watching the podcast on the living
room TV when my roommate walked past and
said, "Hey, that guy looks like John
Wayne Gacy." At first I thought she was
joking, but I remembered that she's a
white woman. If she knows anything, it's
true crime. And sure enough, a quick
Google search yielded some undeniable
results. At first I thought the
similarities were minor, surface level
stuff. Round face, shadowy caterpillar
of a mustache, creepily elongated ears.
But I kept searching and started to
realize that these similarities were
much deeper. Both were comedians and
entertainers, both were active in
politics, and above all, the eyes. Those
same beady, brownish, lifeless eyes. The
eyes of a man who was capable of
anything. Consider the implications of
this. Officially, John Wayne Gacy was
executed for his crimes, or so we're
told. Could it be? Could Ethan be a
serial killer? Or worse, gay? No, it's
not possible. Or is it? Now, I'm not
snark brains, so I'm not going to make
the claim that Ethan Klein murders and
sexually assaults children. That would
be insane. But it would be equally
insane to pretend that the chances of
that are zero. Really makes you think.
So you go Guys, you can go to
doesethankleinlooklikejohnwaynegacy.com
in the chat there.
And guys, now is a great time. I think
we're Wait, wait, wait, wait. We'll get
to end this first. When is this whole
thing between Ethan and Hasan? It was
never about Israel or Palestine. It was
never really about harassment. This was
always about a 40-year-old former online
hero who torments himself over what
people online are saying about him, and
who completely loses his mind over not
having control over it. He's been losing
subscribers and obsessively coming up
with massive conspiracy theories to
explain why, instead of facing the
obvious, which is that he pretends to be
honest and stand up for things, but he's
a giant cry bully whose only principle
is self-preservation, and he'll sell you
any lie that he can [music] to try to
uphold it, which makes Ethan
>> a [__] weaselly little liar, dude. A
[__] weaselly little liar, dude. For
his efforts, Ethan Klein is the winner
of our first weaselly little liar award,
the sort of a piece of [__] award.
Wow. Mazel tov.
So you'd probably think that vexatious
lawsuits, lying, doxxing, and harassing
smaller figures into silence would be
met with widespread condemnation online,
but actually Ethan is surrounded by a
gang of similarly dishonest creators who
have been clapping like seals at
somebody who has the time and the money
to go after Hasan and his orbit. These
people have a variety of motivations.
Some of them are clout-hungry, some of
them feel personally slighted by Hasan,
and some of them are perhaps just
mentally disabled, but all of them
deserve to be recognized for helping
usher in this new online meta [music]
where there are no standards of behavior
whatsoever, as long as the person on the
other side is named Hasan [__]
Time for the award ceremony.
Let's take a look at Cameron after 05.
Wow. There we go, guys. So, that
is the end of a of a first big segment,
really, of the Ethan part of the video.
Not even halfway through yet.